Chúng quốc 642 đại bắt 3 thợ淩 tùng DED SRAM
trongLeod navини
Điều đường nhân dân ở bắt kinh sáng 18 năm.
Sok Huy đoàn xe của ông Trump tới nơi chú tịch Trung Quốc tập cận bình ra đó bắt ấy tổng thủ Mỹ và giới thiệu quán trước hay bên.
Hài lãnh đạo sau đó bước lên buộc dành dự, quân nhạc cục thường Mỹ và Trung Quốc trong khi
2 mi mút loạn đại bắt vàng lên từ quán trường Thí Dan Môn về đó.
Ông tập và ông Trump giữa độ dành dự trên tham đó, giới đi qua hàng học sinh vợi cơ hay nước.
Sau lễ đó, hài lãnh đạo rút vào đại lấy đường nhân dân để vực đam.
Một quán hệ giữa Mỹ và Trung Quốc sẽ tốt đẹp hơn bao giờ hết.
Đấy là Trung tham Trung Quốc đầu tiên của ông Trump trong yếu kỳ hay, đồng thời là lần đầu một tổng thống Mỹ tới bắt kinh kể từ năm 2013.
Chúng thăm cáo giải ba ngày từ 11.9.